welcome everyone again and thank you so
much for joining this wise line academy
course
um as you may have seen probably in the
description
and as the name implies its purpose is
to serve as an introduction to
blockchain how this technology works
what are the fundamental concepts what
are the main mechanisms behind this
and how they relate to each other um
we're going to uh be having some theory
parts
as you'll see and afterwards following
we'll have some
practical coding uh parts with the
gold uh to apply what we just saw in the
previous concepts
this is the agenda of the course uh
let's just go through it
uh quickly because as you'll see they
are grouped
uh depending on the topics we'll be
looking at the blockchain basics
what are blocks how is the chain formed
and what are the nodes that comprise
this blockchain
afterwards we'll be looking at
transactions which are a very important
part of uh how the blockchain works
also about digital signatures which are
essential uh
for the control of these transactions
and finally a couple of more
abstract concepts such as block mining
water wallets
and followed by the q a session and
before starting as i mentioned we'll
have some practical parts
and the idea of these apart from
applying the concepts
is that at the end we have a very
simplified
but functional example of the main um
functions or the main uh functionality
of a blockchain
so that you can have a clear idea um
next slide please so
uh with that being said i'll leave you
with uh esteban who will talk about the
fundamental
concepts of a blockchain thank you
bernardo
so let's start with asking the question
of what is blockchain
so okay so a simple
and technical description would be
saying that it is a
data structure that holds historical
transactional records
and it ensures security and transparency
but
we can see it as a database database
that holds uh transactional data uh
as simple as that and with transactional
data i mean
not only currencies like uh data like
sending money or sending bitcoin it
could be information
so its main purpose is to have a a track
of of this history across the time
uh next slide please so
as you know blockchain is composed by
blocks it's what its name says but what
is a block
so a block is the fundamental part of
the blockchain
its main purpose is to hold information
so it holds information about the
transactions
that has been made across the time in
the of existence of the blockchain
but also holds information about the
block itself
such as the timestamps which is when
this block was created we will cover
more about the block creation later
but yeah uh also the blocks are
identified by
a hash which is uh unique
and also by a height and the height is
basically how deep
the block is in the blockchain and the
deeper the blood
in the blockchain the more recent this
data is
so uh in this blockchain each one of the
blocks is related by each other
by this hash so can we go to the next
slide please
so as i mentioned
each one of the blocks is linked to each
other by the hash
this hash is calculated accordingly to
the information that the block contains
so uh this can this can be the
transactional data the time it was
created
so this is to create a unique string a
unique uh
a unique key to identify
a block so this this doesn't repeat so
if the information is changes inside the
block
so will the hash of the of the block
so since i mentioned that the each one
of the blocks is related to each other
by the
hash of the previous block well here we
have an example
so here we have three blocks one two and
three and the block three is related to
a number two
by its hash and the number two related
to the number one by its hash
and the number one as you can see since
it doesn't have a previous block
it it is called the genesis block which
is the first
block in the in the blockchain and this
have a dummy
previous hash so because it doesn't
point to anything
so uh according to
to in order to to maintain consistency
for example if we change the
the value of the transactions or
anything any data inside the
block of the in the block number two the
hash will change
right so instead of being six b q q1
it will be a completely another thing
so the block number 3 will not know
who to refer to because the hash 6b
q1 doesn't exist anymore so the
blockchain will lose
consistency uh it will lose sense
also another thing that is important
about blockchain
is that it is a decentralized lecture
what does that mean we will we will
cover
more that about that later but what it
means is that no one holds
authority over the the network uh
and by that it means that there is not a
single person that
that decides what goes in and how it
goes inside
the blockchain so can we go to the next
slide please
pretty much so yeah to make this simpler
we made an
analogy so basically
this is a book so we want to add a new
page inside the book
so we have a uh a couple of editors that
basically made the consensus to decide
whether this page is
added or not inside the book so
they together make a decision for
example in this example they
say yeah this page that can be added to
this book
so once they make a consensus it is
added to the book
so if the editors decide
that um or or at least the majority
decide that
it doesn't have to be inside the book
well it is not added
so in this same way works the the
blockchain so in this case the book
would be the blockchain the page would
be the blocks
the the editors would be the notes we
will talk
more this in the next slide please
so the notes are basically the
participants inside the the blockchain
so these are the ones that as i
mentioned they make a consensus of
whether the new information should be
added
or not inside the the blockchain
these are the ones that receive the
messages
so the messages could be new
transactions
and they emit the this new information
through
to the whole blockchain and once this
message is emitted
i mean this new transaction they decide
whether this information is consistent
or not and if they
if it should be added or not inside the
blockchain so
each one of them other nodes are
connected through each other
using a peer-to-peer protocol
so there's no central hub no there's not
a single node that
can take arbitrary the
whole decisions of inside the blockchain
so each one of these
holds a copy of the whole blockchain
this helps them decide whether the new
information
makes sense or not for the for the rest
of the of the blockchain
so can we go to the next slide
so in a summary we can say that
blockchain is a decentralized
database basically no one holds
authority over the whole network
it is a peer-to-peer network as we can
as we
just mentioned each one of the nodes are
connected each one can emit
and can receive messages they can vote
whether a new transaction should be
added or not inside the blockchain
and also it is immutable this has to do
that it is hard to to to change the
information of
of the of the blocks it
it would lose sense if we try to do that
so the information inside the blockchain
cannot be changed
next slide please
so i'll leave you with a bit which will
help us through uh
showing us an example of how blockchain
works through code
okay so this is a bit once again
let me share my screen just we can
start calling a little bit
wait a second okay
so let's get started um i
want to introduce you how we are going
to
um we're going to start developing this
uh practical course uh we will
split this uh practical exercise into
three parts
sorry can you make your font larger
please yeah
sorry thank you thank you for the
reminder is that okay
that's perfect thank you okay cool so as
i
was mentioning we will split this course
into three parts as the theory goes
forward
uh let's start first with the previous
concept
that we have seen before that is for
example how
a blog is created what are the main
properties of a block
data block has and
another file that we will be
creating for setting up pretty much all
the configuration for
our blockchain application let me just
uh this is a very small application
building javascript so
we are not using any hard thing to
understand just plain javascript and we
are using nodejs to
just install some dependencies for our
application to run right
so uh having said that let's begin with
the course uh if you see we have
uh two files so far now this file will
describe pretty much how
a block will look like for our
application
and as steven was mentioning we will be
starting describing the main properties
for our block
so you see we have a timestamp
this is just to unidentify a unique
identify for
for this block right and we will have a
second property
for holding the transaction remember
that a block can have transaction
and for example in talking about
blockchain
specifically blocks not only can have
transactions but for example it can have
any
type of data that you want to process
within the blockchain
there are some examples that for example
manage
official documents for make sure that
they are
authentic and there are lots of examples
that it is not are not related just
cryptocurrencies right so for this
example we are
just using uh some coins to store
in here some transactions transferring
some coins
and we will have another property that
is the previous hash
as steven was mentioning every block is
chained together
with the previous one so that we can
make sure that we have
that chain pattern right and uh
let's add a third property a fourth
property
this is the nonce and we are going to
explain later what's the purpose of
of this property for now let's define it
as an integer
uh with zero value as a default
and we are going to use another property
we are going to create another property
called the hash
and for now we are going to set an empty
string for it
right if you can see we have
one method in here and let's start
calling it
remember that each block needs to have a
hash representation
a a hash is is nothing more than
a string representation passing some
input data
in this case we are going to pass the
properties of a block
to the hash function and for the
hash function algorithm we are going to
use the chat
256 algorithm and this is just to
generate the hash right so let's
start creating our hash for this block
and what we're going to do is say call
the function chat from
256 and we are going to start to start
passing for example the timestamp
and we are going to concatenate pretty
much every property of a block
and we are going to say this dot
transaction
but as this is an array sorry i just
missed here this is an empty array and
uh sorry
we are going to as this is an array we
are going to json stringify
this way so that it converts into a
string
and we can just concatenate with other
strings right
and we are going to say this dot
uh previous hash
and we are going to concatenate
these dot nuns uh now
that we are using the nonce property uh
we are going to touch in depth
how this is used but for now these nodes
will give
will give us the opportunity to start
generating a different hash
every time that we add them to minor
block
uh when it comes to mining blocks
remember that
we need to start calculating a hash for
the block that is going to be added to
the chain so
no don't worry we are gonna show you how
this
this works for the lessons but for now
this is the
the variable that will let let us
generate a different hash
for the for the given block right so
okay that's it for the blog file uh
let's go
let's jump to the blockchain file and
here we are gonna pretty much
uh say how our application is going to
behave
so let's start finding some properties
uh we're
we are i'm gonna create the property
called change
and obviously as you may know this is
blockchain we will need a way to store
every block that is added to the chain
so for that we are gonna
store those blocks in this property and
obviously this is an array
for that for now i'm just creating this
as an empty right
and i'm going to create another property
in here that is
difficulty and for blockchains
that uh use something called
uh well for the consensus protocol uh
maybe we are going to see this
for the lessons uh for this example we
are simulating a blockchain that use
proof of work
uh for example in the case of width of
bitcoin that uses
proof of work it means that for every
block
that needs to be added to the chain some
miners or computers that
are in the peer-to-peer network needs to
find or to solve a mathematical problem
and the one who solves that mathematical
problem is the one
that has the rights to add the given
block
into the into the chain right so this
variable in here
will help us to the to set the
difficulty for mining a block
you will see later how this work in
action but for now let's have this in
mind
we are going to create a third property
for pending transactions
and as uh
every transaction before it can be
submitted to the blockchain
needs to be evaluated before right so
what's evaluated in the process we need
to evaluate that for example transaction
calls valid information that is a valid
recipient
and a valid uh sender right
and obviously for example validating
that funds
uh are enough to send depending
the the people who is sending the coins
and uh
in real world uh this is a very much
complex property because
it is involved a lot in there but for
now let's just define this array that
will hold every transaction that we want
to add to the blockchain
and we are going to add a very very
simple validation
whether the transaction is valid or not
they can be added to the chain
right and finally we are gonna
create a four property called mining
reward
mining reward and uh
for the consensus protocol that is when
a
a node mines a block
and it can be added to the chain the
the computer or the node that wins
or solves this mathematical problem
receives a reward
for the work right so for this example
we are going to say that sorry this is
not an empty right
this is just a number and we are going
to say that
the node that is capable to mine a
certain blog
will receive uh 100 coins as the reward
for
for mining right so here you can see the
the concept of the mining in blockchain
right you
for example deploy a node with the
software that
can mine transactions and you receive
coins for
your computer to do the work right so
that's the idea behind
mining uh if you see
below we have two more methods create a
genesis block
as stephen mentioned uh the first block
added to the chain
is called the genesis block so let's uh
implement this function and what we are
going to do here is just create a blog
class that is from the blog file
and we are going to say new block
and we are going to pass the timestamp
for javascript
we use the date dot now function it
returns
the the unix timestamp and
we are gonna pass an empty transactions
array as this is the first block in the
chain
we don't have any transactions coming
through the network right
so we just said an empty right and for
the previous hash
uh here we set an empty string because
you know this is the first block there
are no previous
uh blocks behind it so
that's it we have our genesis block
created
and let's go back to the constructor and
for these
let's create the mk right but this time
let's use the function that we created
and that's it once we initialize this
blockchain class we will have our
genesis block created
right at the instance moment and let's
code the last method for that
in blockchain it's very youtube to know
which is the latest block in the chain
that is called the hate
the height as steven mentioned so let's
return the last item on our
chain variable and for that we are going
to use the last
index on this property
right and yeah that's pretty much it
uh we are going to continue with the
theory
uh this is the way that we are going to
work once we
cover more concepts we go back to the
practical lessons so we can see those in
action right
so uh i think i
leave you guys with 7 right
yes there you go
okay so now we will continue with the
transactions of the blockchain how they
work
our next slide please
so next one please
so basically as we mentioned the blocks
contains
transactional information so they can
have multiple transactions inside of
them
so a single transaction is basically a
small unit
of a public record so
this public record could be an exchange
of currency but not
necessarily it could mean like an
exchange of information
a signature or or something else
so as as i mentioned before
if you try to change information of a
block it will change the hash
of the block but this also applies for
the for the transactions because each
one of the transactions has a hash
and also has information related to
the persons who sends the the
transaction and who receives it
and also information like the amount of
in this example
is for example an exchange of currency
so it says the amount of currency sent
and also the timestamp which refers to
the time
the the transaction was created
so can we go to the next slide
so so digital signing this is for
sending
transactions so we can think of this
like uh when you create an account in a
bank
so for that you need an account
so so to start sending transactions you
need an account
so for this you you need
in blockchain you need two things uh the
public key and the private key
these are mathematically generated this
could in
in a bank it would mean uh your account
and for example in your plastic you have
uh a number for your card and also
uh the three numbers in the back right
so the public key
is basically the one that you could
share with anyone they want
this is the information that you could
identify yourself publicly
so for example transported to the back
to the bank example
these you can you can share your for
example your account number
or your 60 numbers of your card so you
so
you can ask for a transaction of money
right
and the private keys should be always
kept secret so
for example the three numbers in the
back or the
date of your card in this example
so this allows for accountability uh the
point of in
blockchain is not to secure or encrypt
the message itself
it is to secure the point of origins or
for example to ensure
that the transactions that are sent are
sent
by you and no one else so that's why you
shouldn't share your private key because
if someone else
has your private key they could send
transactions
in your name so next slide please
so this is a graphical examples for
example you try to send a message
across the the network so you sign
a message with your own key so then then
you send it to the network
so they can all verify that that message
actually comes from you
so next one please
so we will cover this part in the coding
[Music]
example with david
okay uh so going back to
our um
our files let's
continue with what stephen was
mentioning about the
transaction and signing so uh
for that let's add a third
method into the blog
file so this will validate uh
the the current transactions for this
block
uh let's just think for a moment
that uh this method is implemented i'm
gonna
write a check in here and we are going
to use
for each transaction on the block if you
see we are using
for loop to iterate over the
transactions property of the block
and for each transaction we will need to
check if that transaction is valid
so this method is not implemented yet
but
uh later we're going to implement it
right this is this will return a boolean
value saying that is valid or not true
or false
if that is not the case we are just
returning false
if everything goes well we'll just
return to the right
and going back to uh the blockchain file
we are gonna sorry another blockchain
file let's
add a third um file
here to describe how transactions will
behave in this
example uh so you hit at the same
goes for for transaction class we define
a constructor having
uh three properties in here we have a
from address
we have two address and an amount this
is this is mostly
the basic properties that a transaction
should comply with
and obviously from address is the is the
one who's saying who tried to send funds
to
add to address this this is the
recipient or the receiver
and the amount of coins that they want
to transfer
right and the same goes for the
transaction
we will need to have a hash
representation of this transaction
object
because we need to make sure right that
the transaction once is added to the
blockchain
uh we need a way to validate
that this transaction hasn't been
changed over time right
so we are pretty much doing the same
with the block we are going to use the
chat
256 algorithm to create a hash
representation
and we are going to pass uh
the same uh properties that we have in
the constructor
that is dot from address
we're gonna concatenate the
um to address and also
the amount
this dot amount okay cool
and uh let's
just add a third method here this is for
signing the transaction as steven
mentioned
we will need a way to identify ourselves
into the blockchain
and that is the the purpose of the
keypairs
so every key pair holds obviously two
two keys uh one is the public one
and the other one is the private one so
for example you can see this as an
analogy for example the pla the public
key is your user id
in facebook and your private key is your
password right
you share your username or your user id
in facebook but
not your password right this is the same
for blockchain you share with others
your public key
so they can send you phones or recognize
you within
the network and your password is just to
authorize
to send coins within the network and you
only hold that
that private key right so let's uh
code this sign transaction method uh in
here we just receive a key pair
this is just uh we're using a library
called
elliptic this is for managing
cryptographic functions for keypairs
in javascript you can just look for it
on npm
and it's the whole documentation if any
dots
so we are using that keypair and the
first thing we are going to do
is later when we start coding the mining
process we will need
we will need to ensure that
we will need to identify whether this
transaction is for a
reward mining for those blocks that for
example
mine some for those accounts for those
nodes that mine some blocks
and if that is the case we will just set
the from address to
node you will see further in action and
with return true this is a valid
transaction right
and uh let's just
make use of the key pair that we're
receiving here we are gonna get
the the x string representation of the
key pair
you can get the the the key
representation
in any encoding you want for now we are
going to use the hexadecimal
encoding and we are going to say if the
x representation of the key pair that we
are receiving here is different from the
address that is sent sending the
transaction
obviously we don't we don't have the
permissions to sign transaction for
others
right so for example you create a
transaction
and let's say that your friend was wants
to
to send those cons for you that is not
possible because you need
a way to authenticate yourself and your
friend doesn't have your private key
right
so that way we make sure that no one can
sign transaction for others
and uh let's just
add a couple of um properties in here
let's
create a property called hash
and uh for that
let's say this dot
calculate hash i'm gonna use the
function that i just created
before this one and once we have the
property hash
we are gonna create the sign the
signature for this hash
so in a few words what we sign in here
is just
the the hash representation of this
block uh that's the way that
cryptographic functions
works so let's say uh
let's create a variable called sign
and let's return let's use the keeper
so we see repair and we are going to use
a method called sign
obviously this is going to sign the
transaction cache for
us and let's
call let's copy this in here we're gonna
sign the hash of this transaction
and we are going to pass a second
parameter that is
the encoding that we are going to use
for having for creating the
the signature right there as well lots
of encoding
for this example we are going to use
base64
and once we have the signature we are
going to use
another method
to just create the signature property in
here
let's call it dot signature and this
signature will hold
this property in here will hold the
signature that we just created before
but in another format right
sorry it's sign dot
to there this is another
encoding that we use to represent the
signature
and sorry this is in may use
to there in
in here we're gonna use the x the x
encoding
once again this is pretty much a
standard in
pretty much all blockchains out there
they
they represent the signature index
encoding and obviously you can for
example verify
if the given signature corresponds to
any public key we are going to do that
in for the lessons and once we have the
signature let's
just print it out and
that's it for our transaction class
and i think we can continue with the
theory uh
let's do a very quickly recap what we do
we create the
transaction class we obviously add a
hash represent a method to calculate the
hash representation for this transfer
for this transaction class and we add
a sign transaction method which will
receive a key pair
obviously this this key pair will need
to match
to the from address so that we just make
sure that the person who sends the coins
is the same that wants to sign the
transaction or in other words to
authorize this transaction
we created the signature property for
the transaction class
and obviously we send the transaction we
sign the hash
uh with this transaction object
and that's pretty much it let's continue
with the theory
i'm sorry to interrupt you third a bit
before we continue
um just to open a small
very small space for any blocking
questions
now that we're passing into the last
block
of theory i know we've been covering a
lot of uh
and as someone just asked in the channel
uh well in the chat sorry we've already
shared the repo but
uh we'll we can share the link again i
know we can
be going a little bit fast uh because of
time
constraints but the idea is that you
just follow along with us right now and
if it's too fast you can revisit the
code
but is everything good so far uh
anyone has something in which they are
lost
that they would like to clarify
uh yeah i just saw the question that you
posted on the chat
uh yeah just for keeping things
as easily as possible we just manage one
address for wallet but for example in
more complex
examples we certainly can have
multiple keepers that can manage some
funds or in this case to have a
centralized wallet to manage some funds
but for this
example let's just think or let's just
use
a one key pair just to keep things as
easy as possible but yeah that's
possible that's a good question
indeed
awesome and because i just shared the
repo again
in the chat so if anyone was missing it
you can look at it right there so just
sorry sorry just want to add something
really quick
don't think as all the coding we're
doing as a specific point
or for a specific technology this is
more of an abstraction
it it has a lot a huge amount of weak
points
so this should in any way be used as a
production environment of any kind
but it is more to illustrate how these
basic
uh theoretical parts of a blockchain
work together
in a more practical way in the code so
it was just a quick note and anyway
don't try to
look for what is from any other
blockchain it's just to illustrate in
more practical ways
exactly and as part of that as we even
mentioned not all transactions in a
blockchain
are even asset transfers uh we're doing
that example because it's like the most
uh day-to-day one or the most familiar
to most people
but yeah it's just a way for us to
illustrate it
and luis is asking should we be coding
alone
along uh no it's what i'm saying i mean
if you
want to you're welcome to do it uh but
if we're going too fast uh don't feel
like you're
falling behind uh we'll in the repo
you'll see
the final version with all the code so
if you
uh start lagging behind you won't miss
anything
you can have the complete code in there
and well maybe for time constraints we
can continue
answering the the questions in the
chatbot i think we can continue with the
theory so as you can see we're missing
the
block mining wallets and and that's it
so i'll leave you with let me
okay thank you arnold could you go to
the next slide please
okay so i'm gonna be talking about two
other concepts are basics to the
blockchain technologies which are mining
and consensus
okay so let's talk about mining
as we seen before there's uh
a collection of transactions that are
expected to be added to the blockchain
in the coding example this was a
variable called
pending transactions so notes have to
take transactions for that pool of
transactions
and verify them
that's the way that blocks are mine
this is different from coins to coins
but the
most common example is proof of work
this is used by bitcoin so in this
process
the miner you know has to have that new
block
and is cashing over and over again
until it complies with a arbitrary
constraint this constraint is just used
to make it
harder to to get a valid block
so once the first miner gets
this hash it can be sent to the
blockchain
and this node is rewarded so miners are
indeed getting paid for their work as
auditors
and in this process also new coins are
generated
that's the reason we call this mining we
are creating
some new coins one every time we mine a
new block
let's slide please so yeah
once uh blocks mine a a number of nodes
have to agree
that this block is correct this is what
we call
consensus and we do this because
we don't rely on a single entity our
trust is not put on a single node
instead of that we have to rely on a
part of the whole network so
it is only until a number of nodes agree
that a block is valid
that we can include it to the chain
let's slide please yeah so in this
diagram
you can see uh the whole transaction
process
it starts with regret create a
transaction and sign it
so for example let's say that alice
wants to send both some coin
uh a hundred coin alice has to create a
transaction
and she has to sign the transaction
using his
her private key uh after that
the data transaction gets submitted
and some not a mines a new block
including this new transaction
after that we can send that block
we broadcast this log to some of the
other nodes
and these nodes have to verify that
blocks content
this is the consensus process once that
those nodes reach consensus we can be
sure
that this block is valid so until that
we produce new coins which are rewarded
to the miners and
after that this new block is added to
the blockchain
and distributed to the whole chain
and this is the last step for
transaction and once
that's done we can say that this
transaction is confirmed
hey could you go to the nets like this
yeah so this last last topic is wallets
that's like this yeah so a wallet is a
secure place to store and access your
private keys
which are used for address generation
and signing transactions
maybe a better analogy rather than
wallet is a keychain or a
[Music]
checkbook because the coins are not
stored in the wallet
you you use the wallet to sign
transactions
so similar to a checkbook you write
checks using your signatures
and you use that to send funds
if you lost your wallet
and talking about that blockchain wallet
you should be able to recover all your
funds if you have the
keys associated to it and
yeah if someone sends your
cryptocurrency it means it is assigned
to the address of your blockchain while
it
will record it in a distributed layer
not the wallet itself
let's select this i'm talking about
privacy and security
the blockchain technology has some
advantages
uh advantages about this uh some of them
are that they do not require
personal data to be provided they will
just rely
on hashes and keys another party has to
store
your sensible information so in case you
don't want to
share any update you shouldn't have to
information stored in blockchain is
considered immutable
once it is recorded it cannot be changed
to change the state of a blockchain
you have to create new blocks and not
that whole history of transformations
get stored so that makes makes
it more secure and finally this
information decentralization increases
availability
and removes single points of failure so
even if
in a given network there are some
malicious
entities they won't be able to
do something bad by themselves because
of the mechanisms that we
talked about before such as consensus
this makes the blockchain technology
uh more secure and reliable
i think we can go back to the coming
time
yeah thank you nami uh let me just
share my screen once again
okay cool so yeah i know that we have
seen
how
a consensus process is made of
let's just try to reproduce it into
our practical example so
let's do a quick recap so we now we have
the blog file blockchain file
transaction
and we will add a fourth one called
wallet
this is for mapping what we just saw in
theory regarding wallets
and uh let's
go back to our blog file
and we're gonna
add a forward method that is called the
mind block
and for this method uh remember that the
consensus process
needs to in a way in a way
solve a mathematical problem so for that
what i'm going to do is just
use the brute force uh this is uh
certainly some blockchains use this
protocol most of them are the proof of
work
and this is just trying to recreate in a
hash
obviously changing one particularly that
on the hash function remember that we
have the nonce
property so this nonce property will
help us to create a different hash
each time that we attempt to create one
during the consensus
process right so why we have to create a
new hash every time
remember the property that we have in
the blockchain class
called difficulty
so for example in proof-of-work
blockchains
what we will need to do is attempt to
create a new hash
let's start coding i'm gonna say
east.hash
and i'm gonna pick a slice of this
string we are gonna use the substring
function in javascript
and i'm gonna pick the from the zero
index
to the difficulty property that we have
in in the blockchain so as
you can as you can see we receive the
difficulty property in here
so we use that to cut the string out and
what we are going to do with that string
is
we are gonna uh
compare and we and here i'm gonna use uh
a function in javascript with the right
class and i'm gonna say
at the arrive i'm gonna create an array
with
length of difficulty plus one
and once i have created this array i'm
gonna join
i'm gonna use the join function what
this is going to do is create an
array with this length
and then convert every this array
into a string containing the number
of zeros which i give in this
probe as this property here right so for
example if we pass the difficulty as
three
we will receive a number four in here
and what we have as an output we will
have a string with
three zeros and remember the difficulty
is to set the difficulty of the
blockchain but why we need to set that
difficulty
remember the mathematical problem that
we need to solve for
adding some blocks in the consensus
process so for example in blockchain i
think we need to
create a hash that has i think
eleven zeroes at the beginning so
as you can see at the first attempt we
do it's
most is likely impossible to have this
result right
so miners need to have very need to have
a powerful resources to compute these
kind of problems
so that is uh that is the the idea to
to mining right because computers are
trying so hard to find
uh those hashes that meet the difficulty
in this case having
a hash or finding a hash that will meet
three serials at the beginning right
this is very simple difficulty
for uh for keeping examples
easy but as i mentioned for bitcoin
i think there is 11 series
before each hash so you can imagine the
incredible amount
of power that we need to mine those kind
of hashes right
and obviously the the the node
that is um able to find this or to solve
this problem
is the one who claims the reward
and can add the next chain the next uh
node into the chain right so for now uh
we are going to use the nodes
property here and each time we attempt
to create a new hash
we are going to increase the month
and if you remember we initialize the
nonce to zero
because every attempt we are going to
increase this property right and
once we increase this property this will
let us to create a different hash if you
remember we are passing it in here and
if we change
any data here we are gonna get a
different
output hash from this algorithm function
so once we increase the cache we are
gonna
say this dot hash and we are gonna
recalculate
the hash using our function from above
so this one over here so we increase the
hash the first iteration
we create another hash if this is not
meeting the criteria that we want to
find the hash right so that's it
for creating for mining
let's just add a couple of console logs
just to at the end that we can run this
application we can see
pretty much what's happening what's
happening behind sense right
we're going to log the nodes at which we
find the hash that meets
that criteria and the hash itself
so uh let's go back to the blockchain
file
and for this i'm gonna add
four methods in here uh we can
have pretty much uh some validations in
here that
don't matter too much but let's create
a method that will let let us add a
transaction
right so we receive the transaction
object and this is obviously as
a part of the consensus process right to
form some blocks
with transactions so before we can add a
transaction to
the blockchain or to a block uh we need
to validate
the from address and to others right so
every transaction as i mentioned before
needs to have
a valid from address and a valid to
address if that is not the case
we cannot add this transaction to the
chain
and we are gonna validate it we are
going to use
this method that we are going to create
later in here but for now
we are going to use this method to
ensure that each transaction is valid
right
if that is not valid obviously we are
going to throw an error
and the last thing we're gonna do is if
all these checks
are passing in here we're gonna say that
the transaction is valid
and for that what we are gonna do is use
the pending transactions array
is that pending transaction equal to
sorry
dot push and the transaction that we are
receiving
here right so we use transaction
and uh according to this comment
uh the main pool is the same as spending
transactions right
so mempool is fairly the
standard name in blockchain to name this
pending transaction
so in these places where miners start
picking
the transactions as they come in right
so one way
miners can start filtering out
transaction
is according to one property called the
fee when you send a transaction in the
blockchain you need to specify
some sort of attacks for using the
blockchain and that is called the fee
and every transaction that you send
through the network needs to have this
property
the fee and validators are taking those
transactions that have
the higher fees so the the higher fees
you specify into
your transactions the more likely a note
a validate or no
bigger transactions to be processed
right so there are cases for example in
blockchain that if you specify a very
minimum
a fee your transaction can uh
lay on this property in this main pool
four days
until until a uh
note can start considering your
transactions to be processed
right so this is a very important thing
to remember
uh the fees for each transaction and
let's add another method this is my
independent transaction
as i told you this transaction needs to
pass
through a process for validate them
validated them but first of all let's
just
create a variable in here
that is going to point to the latest
block in the chain
remember that before we can add
transactions to a block
and afterwards we add that block into
the chain we need to
chain together then you've logged to the
latest one
so what we are going to do here is just
i'm going to
stop some code just to speed up things
up
and uh what i'm gonna do here is just
created getting the last block in the
chain using the
the utils that we have defined above and
uh then we're gonna create a new block
passing the timestamp we are gonna pass
the pending transaction because these
transactions are the ones
that needs to be included in this new
block
and if you see we make use of the
cache of the previous block remember
that the third property
here is the previous hash so we point to
the
previous hash in this plot and
once this is uh once we have the
the block variable created we are going
to say log
dot mind block this is the function that
we
created a couple of minutes ago this one
and we're going to pass the difficulty
this
dot difficulty
and okay once we have mind.log
we are gonna push the block in in the
chain
we are gonna say that this block was
mined successfully and once we have
mined this block we can add it to the
chain right and the remember
that once we once a validator
minds a blog it receives
a reward so remember that after we
mine a blog what we are going to do is
uh
add a new reward transaction to the
pending transaction so once we mine
pretty much all transactions that user
sent to the network
the first transaction of the next block
will be a reward
for the block for the the validator that
actually mined the last block right
so that's it we have our mind pending
transaction
and this these two methods here are just
like
very util so uh
we are gonna forget in a balance the
balance is the amount of
coins that you have in the given address
so
what we are going to do here is iterate
over each block in the chain
and then for each transaction on the
current block
and we are gonna say that
if
if transaction
sorry
[Music]
i lose my cursor yeah
if transaction dot
from address is different from
uh the address that we receive in this
method
this is the address to know the balance
of so
so we from address is equal to the
others that we want to know
that is that we send coins out right so
we're gonna say
the balance property that we have above
we're gonna say balance
equals minus
one and the amount right
because if the address the given address
is on the from
property this means that we that that
address
send coins to another person if that is
the case
where
this transaction dot 2
address is equal to the address it means
that we receive coins
from this
from this transaction right so what
we're going to say here is just
add the amount to the balance and at the
end
what we are going to do is just uh
return the balance right and
we have added the last method in this
class just to validate that pretty much
our trend our blockchain object
will be validated by these functions so
if you see we
we are iterating over each block in the
in the in the chain
and we are going to get the current
block and the previous block
and this is going to do three
validations in here we are going to
check if all transactions in the block
are valid
and how we do that is just saying that
has valid transactions
from the block remember that we have
coded that method in here
and we are going to add a
third validation in here to check if the
current block cache is valid
and for that we are going to say the
current block
dot hash is different from and again we
are going to recalculate the hash
because this function is going to
give us the current cash state of this
block right
if we castrally change some data in here
this is going to be different from the
actual cache right so that way we make
sure that
or we realize that someone else changed
that time to the into the block right
so obviously if that happens the chain
is not valid
because something bad happened something
did intentionally
this change and obviously this is
considered invalid
and that is the case we turn false if
not
we are going to have a third validation
that is to check the previous cache
remember that if we change the data of
any block
its hash will be recalculated so the
blocks that were chained together
back with it will invalidate the
previous hash
right so if you see we take the previous
cash block we recalculate the hash
and with the current block we get the
previous cash um property
and if someone someone changed data
between those blocks
we will know with this validation right
because
obviously our calculate hash function
will
uh throw a different output if some
changes some data change
and uh finally let's go back to our
transaction file and let's add
a the last method here to check the if
the transaction is valid
or not and for that we're gonna use
a different method
from the keeper sorry not the key pair
but we are using another library
representing the key pairs
that is the elliptic one and we're gonna
say we're gonna
obtain the public key from the address
of the transaction right in a next in an
extra decimal format
so using this method here getting the
public key
once we have the public key uh
we are gonna verify and what we are
going to verify
here is the hash for this transaction
actually
corresponds to the to the method here
and so this needs to be
in here right so this way we ensure that
uh the given address actually
sign the transaction right this verify
method will check the hash
of this transaction and the signal the
actual signature
of of the the transaction and this
method
behind the sense uses cryptographic
functions to delete
if the the given signal the given
address was
created uh the c the given signature was
created using this address right
and uh finally we're going to create a
four
file called the wallet address and once
we have seen in theory
how a wallet behaves uh
i'm gonna add two functions that is
create wallet how to create a key pair
using the electric function in
javascript and how to validate
if the given public key belongs to the
private key that we are saying right
so we go back to theory
okay so with that we've covered
all of the topics that we have for today
um
so i know we're having uh we're having
an interesting conversation in the chat
but now it's time
uh to ask all your questions um
we're having the session right now um uh
also
can we go to the next slide please check
out
uh we're going to take advantage of this
time while we discuss and we
uh answer all of your questions to put
this feedback survey on screen so that
you can
start answering it it helps a lot to
know your opinion on the course
uh on the contents of it how it was
presented
but we'll just leave it there so that
you have it as a reference but we can
start
taking any questions that you may have
[Music]
i do have a question if i may guys
thanks a lot for the session
uh it was great uh the first question i
it comes to my mind is you mentioned
that we have a public and private key
and i cannot stop thinking of hey i had
a leakage
of my private keys so
is there a chance since i understand
that we cannot change anything in the
blockchain is there a chance to
replace that with a new private key as
soon as i
got it stolen let's say somehow because
that might represent the security
bridge right i mean the whole mechanism
if it's not
uh the other one i have is
uh i've seen in the news that sometimes
there are some
uh providers please forgive me if i i
don't say
properly that they were offering like
uh like virtual wallets you had your
wallets i think
through them and they all of sudden
disappear
so uh is
is all of the information for those
all of the all of the customers relying
on them
already lost already gone or is there a
way to
uh recover that
okay so maybe i can take on the first
question um
yeah so because of the nature of how the
addresses work and this is common for
most blockchains i've come across
because it's so
uh intrinsic to how the technology works
is that
your private key is basically what gives
you complete access to your address
because even
as you as we mentioned public keys are
derived from your private key so these
they have like a mathematically rela
uh relation that cannot be changed and
therefore it's not as
we put that as an example to have a more
day-to-day
scenario but it's not as a password that
you can just change
most addresses in a blockchain are
directly derived from your private key
and that's why
you can share your public key and that's
how the rest of the network will verify
uh as we saw right so if for any reason
your private key gets compromised and
someone
has access to it they get complete
access to your funds
so the that's why it's so important
and it's there's such an
emphasis on you keeping your private
keys safe because it's the only way you
can recover those funds
if you lose that private key you won't
be able to recover them
either so this is like a double-edged
sword
uh it gives you and it's one of them
of the reasons why blockchain
enthusiasts
think it's a good technology to be used
because you're in complete control
but therefore you also have the complete
responsibility to keep it safe
if you get your private key
exposed the best thing to do is to just
transfer those funds as fast as possible
to another account that you have access
and no one else has
um so i think that answers your first
question
is that where you were yes thanks okay
and the second question i think you
refer to exchanges right
all these platforms that help you
just manage your accounts and your
wallets and that you've seen some cases
in which they get hacked
and a lot the funds are lost is that
where you're
yeah and i i think i read in the news
like
perhaps three months back something like
that that there was a broker
and it all all of a sudden it was
gone and nobody knew what happened there
so i think it's more related to that
yeah
okay yeah so when you use one of these
platforms they have a lot of benefits of
course
they help you manage your wallets and
they are like a bridge
for you to buy new cryptocurrencies or
trade between them
because for most most users uh
interacting directly with a blockchain
is simply not
friendly at all so these platforms exist
for this
they also give you the opportunity to
store your keys for you
and that's why you can get some recovery
options with them
but you'll also like this could be the
weakest
link in the security of the blockchain
because
in the blockchain itself you it can't be
hacked
or just you have like the majority of
the power
um or the presence in the blockchain is
how you could maybe influence it
but in bitcoins such as bitcoin ethereum
all of those is virtually impossible to
have
the majority of the computing power but
in the case so it's basically not it's
what we were mentioning now
it's one of the greatest things of
blockchain is that information is
immutable
but in the moment that you have an
intermediary such as these brokers
having your keys then you're trusting
the security in them so in this case
i'm not sure exactly what was the news
uh
but in those cases what got compromised
was the
the platform itself someone got the
private keys from them or even the
in some cases even the the owners of the
platform have made use of this
and as i mentioned if you have the
private key you can do whatever you want
with these funds
so i think it's an important distinction
to make
if if you hear this kind of news it's
not that the blockchain was compromised
in most of the cases it was one of these
platforms
cool awesome thanks for that no problem
any other questions something you'd like
to discuss
we might have uh fell behind in the chat
so if anyone didn't get your question
answered in the chat
please go ahead
if not then i think david you wanted to
do a last recap right with everything we
did in the
in the practical part maybe we have time
just to close everything yeah
yeah that would be very useful i'm going
to show you how
uh this uh what we did guys uh
is in action i'm gonna run the
application let me just
share my screen so that you can see
how all these concepts are
placed into a real world example
okay uh are you saying my discord
right yes
yes awesome cool so
uh once we have completed the four files
that we have in here
i was just missing the fourth one i'm
going to explain very quickly what i did
i'm going to create a another method
called create wallet
and i'm going to use uh i'm going to
make use of
this library that i mentioned earlier
the listing library to create
everything pair a public and a private
one and i'm going to create another
function to derive
the private the public key from the
private one this is very useful in some
blockchains to verify the authenticity
of both
keypairs of a key pair and i'm going to
return true if
the given private key matches the public
key right
and once we have that in place we can
just run our example i have prepared a
very
uh to debug our application and i'm
gonna
do i'm gonna create an instance of our
blockchain class
so this will uh mine the transactions
create a transaction for us and and all
that stuff
i'm gonna use the create wallet method
that we saw
uh just earlier to create wallets for my
wallet
and for ali's wallet following the
example that we saw
that we saw on the slides and what i'm
gonna do is just
uh i'll put in those key pairs
and i'm gonna create the first
transaction
passing the public key from my wallet
i'm gonna transfer some fonts to ali's
wallet using
his her private key and i'm gonna
transfer
uh this amount of coins 60 coins
then i'm going to sign the transactions
with the with my wallet keeper since i'm
the one who signed this transaction
once i sign the transaction i'm gonna
add the transactions to
the blockchain and i'm gonna
after i add this transaction to the
blockchain i'm gonna
mine that transaction using our simple
blockchain
object obviously passing my wallet
right and uh i'm gonna do the same for
other
two transactions so in total we will
have three transactions created
each transaction will be included into a
blog when we call the mind pending
transactions remember that
the consensus process is in action and
every transaction that is in the pending
transactions array
will be included in the next block
right and i'm gonna do a um
a couple of things below here
what i'm gonna do is just after i did
the transactions i'm gonna check for the
balance
ali at least balance and i'm gonna use
the get balance address right so this
will output
how many coins they have for the given
public key
and then i'm gonna call the is valid
chain this would remember that this
is just to validate if everything in the
in the network is
okay if no none of the blocks has been
altered
or modified or even transactions this
will output true
and afterwards i'm gonna change
one data of one of the transactions i'm
gonna
modify it and say that i just
transferred 200 funds
from 200 coins and obviously as i
changed
some data this function will output
false because
remember that we recalculate the hash
for each transaction and for each node
and the hashes will be different right
after i change this property and at the
end i'm gonna just print
preprint and json format
what our simple blockchain object looks
like right
so let's do a debug
i'm gonna run and as you can see
let me just make
okay over here
so if you can see how we are just
opening some
stuff in here we create the wallet
uh the my wallet public key and private
key and the same for the
alice one right so uh
if you see there are lots of
not lots of blocks there are three
blocks mine
we have the nouns at which we found the
hash and we have
the corresponding caches of each block
right and
if you see we are uh my niche blog
the three the three blocks are in mind
and once we have uh
mine pretty much all the blocks we
output the balance of alice and if you
can see
if you having every amount in the
transaction
you will have this number in here as a
total balance for a list
the first call to the is valid chain
is outputting true and the second one is
false because we already changed
some data right and at the end we have
pretty much
the whole object if you can see uh
this is the genesis block it doesn't
have any transaction
and for each block if you see
we will have uh remember
that difficulty property that we saw if
you see every
block has three zeros at the beginning
this is the first block
it has three zeros then x1 has three
zeros and it's completely different
and obviously we have the reference to
each one we have to the
the first block to the second block it
is referencing to
this block of here the genesis block and
so on for each one
we have the transactions and
we have obviously uh the at the end
we have some uh at the independent
transactions arrived
remember that we had a reward for each
validator
that solve the problem and we have this
uh transaction brief reward for
the last miner and that's pretty much it
as you see we are just implemented a
very basic blockchain using javascript
we will give you the link so you can
play around with it
and i leave you with bernardo
thank you narith we wanted to take the
opportunity to wrap up everything
hopefully that last example uh helped
things uh come together all the concepts
uh
we're running out of time but if anyone
has the last question we're leaving the
feedback survey here
jacob has been sharing it as well in the
chat someone asked if we are planning to
have further
courses related to this and yes stay
tuned for
that this was meant to be an
introduction only
we're planning to make some courses with
more specific topics
someone mentioned smart contracts that
could be part of it
and we'll just dive in a little deeper
and now that you have the foundations so
definitely
stay tuned um i don't know if
anyone has any extra comments from the
team
something you want to add
nope just no thank you guys for
assisting to these cores so hopefully
you can
you enjoy this
awesome thank you very much yeah all
resources will be shared uh the repo the
slides and the recording
um so thanks a lot for joining jacket
anything to add
nothing else thank you everyone thank
you
it was great yeah and i hope you all
have a great afternoon
see you all have a great day bye